now james mcavoy we could not be here
tonight he he is not well he's gonna be
fine but he's in Toronto and he couldn't
join us today I would imagine though
when you're doing he's such a terrific
actor and he's playing how many
different characters is it in this movie
he plays right now I'm still editing it
but right now it's 21 character it's 21
different characters yeah how do you
take Meryl Streep hurts you guys who are
you just going after Streep like that it
isn't right
you can't do what McEvoy can do yeah but
I'm saying what that's my question is
you had a scene it's a very compelling
scene where you would have a kissing
scene with them and I know that you had
trouble doing that scene because it was
I mean you're dealing with such an
intense actor and you don't even know
who he is at that mom I mean to be
perfectly honest I don't think I had
such a hard time with the scene because
I mean James but I think he had a much
harder time because he was playing a
nine-year-old boy kissing me whilst my
eyes were wide open and I was very
clearly uncomfortable and it's night you
know an older man kissing a 19 year old
completely eyes wide open and just being
sort of weird about it
he handled it very well there yeah like
yeah yeah a hard time with that you're
also describing how I kiss now
go in and I have a lot
you